hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday evening that means it's time for
a movie review and today we're doing a
double [__] feature Yeah Yeah we
actually weren't like planning to but we
just watched both of these and I was
like well if we saved one till next week
I probably won't remember enough about
it to like talk about it so uh we might
as well we might as well oh please don't
do that that's kindon of that's like
very distracting yeah very distracting
um but yeah so we're going to do two
Hammer films and uh these ones are not
really in any particular order because
we had been okay so Tom had said that he
wanted to watch the Christopher Lee
Hammer Dracula movies yeah I i' had
never really seen any of them I see I
saw two but they didn't really make a
big impression right like we saw the
first one Horror of Dracula and from
1958 um which is just called Dracula in
Britain but it's called Horror of
Dracula over here and we did a review of
that one and we did ad 1972 Dracula 1972
which I remember liking that one came
out after this one yeah after these two
uh because these two were still kind of
period pieces I like Dracula 80 1972
that was like Hammer trying to you know
bring the vampire into the modern era
because prior to that they were all set
you know in the 19th century or early
20th century so Bastian says the torture
chamber of Dr sadism we will eventually
get around to doing that one because I
noticed that it was on I think it's on
Amazon Prime like for free I've seen it
before but it would be a good one to
review I think um but yeah hey uh Hey
Sebastian hey Tammy uh Hey Walton
Estates hello and good evening from Los
Angeles all the way across the country
that's pretty cool but yeah so we ended
up watching just randomly Dracula has
risen from the grave which is actually
the fourth movie in the series but only
the third with Christopher Lee which
I'll explain in a minute and scars of
Dracula which is the sixth one yeah now
ironically um I didn't actually realize
this when we were watching them Dracula
has risen from the grave generally gets
better reviews than scars of Dracula I
don't understand which well yeah well
most reviewer this is really weird most
reviewers and even on Rotten Tomatoes
like scars of Tom of of Dracula scars of
tomatoes scars of Dracula I can't talk
sorry um has like a 41% rotten like a
you know yeah and I'm just kind of like
I'm gonna go out on a limb and this is
an unpopular horror opinion I like scars
of Dracula better yeah it's better I
liked it better for maybe some of the
reasons that people didn't because it
was just um way gorier and way sleazier
and way more
mean-spirited um and I think that's
probably why I enjoyed it more than well
you you had a lot more you had a lot
more uh Dracula in it too that
he was in it that too and he was doing
cool [__] yeah he was doing like really
cruel horrible [__] which I was kind of
like okay I'm down yeah punishing women
and stuff Disobedience punishing his
servants and and and you got the it
expanded on
um vampire lore and Dracula lore out of
this you know they're they're showing
you new stuff you hadn't seen you yeah
exactly what does Dracula do you know
yeah and I mean I'll get into like a
little bit but like I'm not going to go
into an ex of history behind it but
there is kind of some interesting stuff
about why this movie ended up the way it
did and stuff like that oh Tammy says
love the new skeleton picture in the
back yeah we do have to bring this up uh
our lovely friend of the show Sophie who
has stayed with us many times sent us
that for a wedding present she had that
custom made if you I don't know if you
can see the bottom thank you very much
Walton Estates that's very nice to be
thank you thank you but it says
established 2023 at the bottom so she
sent us that as a wedding present which
I thought was like super cool she didn't
tell us what it was she just said I'm
sending you guys something so like look
out for it yeah so we got it yesterday
you can change what change the color
it's got a bunch of effects and
everything but the camera actually
prefers this particular color and yeah
you can see it the best yeah and if we
if I start pulsing it it'll uh [__] up
the focus on the camera yeah it keeps
like the camera keeps going out of focus
cuz we like it to change colors it looks
really cool but then when we were doing
that like the camera kept going no no no
I don't know if it'll do it with us in
the frame but oh I'm sure it will it
will okay
I could always test and try it out yeah
where's that damn remote it's what it's
right there by it's right there behind
my boov that's where Tammy says Sophie
is a doll she is Sophie is awesome we
love her hopefully she can come visit us
again sometime try okay see that yep oh
yep and the camera went did
it yep it did it again it's like I can't
handle it I can't handle that's funny
it's too much motion but yeah we did
decide that the blue was like stood out
the most yeah I see it yeah see yeah you
see what it's doing you see what it's
doing yeah the camera just does not like
that whatsoever and because it doesn't
help because it's like right in the
center of the frame so we just decided
to leave it like on the solid well until
Tom started [__] with it I'll turn it
around and it's on like it's on two
different circuits yeah yeah you need
two plugs you did it like on a fade deal
yeah you're still going to be doing it
yeah we need like yeah we need like a
solid like we had it before yeah before
you it immediately goes interfere
before you interfered with it he's like
help no I don't okay just go with the
show I don't know how it works all right
so the first one we watched Dracula is
risen from the grave so this one like I
said this is the fourth one so first one
was Horror of Dracula or just Dracula in
the UK uh which was you know the
introduction of Christopher Lee as
Dracula of course so that came out in
1958 and then I wanted to watch Dracula
Prince of Darkness which which I think
is actually the third one the second one
is Brides of Dracula which actually is
available on Amazon Prime but
Christopher Lee isn't in that one the
next one that Christopher Lee is in is
the third one which is Prince of
Darkness now for whatever reason I could
not [__] find Dracula Prince of
Darkness anywhere like it wasn't
streaming anywhere nobody had put it up
for free on YouTube or nothing um maybe
somebody else can find it but I was kind
of looking around and I couldn't find it
so I said well we'll just go to the
fourth one cuz that was available to
rent for like three bucks or something
like that so we decided to watch that
one so this one I feel like now okay now
a lot of the hammer movies even though
they're known for being like you know
bloody and boobalicious and everything
like that this one had some cleavage no
naked boovies yeah it wasn't super
bloody I kind of feel like this one was
a little bit restrained I thought it was
tame for a hammer
movie um in and also I didn't love even
though um you know Christopher Lee had
some lines and stuff in it he doesn't
really he's not in it a lot no he
doesn't say much and he doesn't do much
and I think that was kind of a criticism
that a lot of people had of all of the
later um Christopher leh Hammer Dracula
movies is that well Dracula is kind of
like sidelined in his own story like we
want more Dracula godamn it like we
don't want these stupid young hippies or
whatever the [__] like these young
people in it that are kind of boring
it's like we want to see Dracula like
tearing [__] up you know what I mean
yeah he's not really used as a character
in this movie it's more a lot more like
a prop yeah it's driving the plot but
then when you see him he's just standing
there he could have been a cutout yeah
he doesn't do a whole lot which is a
shame yeah he'll he'll um have like a
lame action scene it'll be like an
action scene on on par with something
out of you know a Star Trek television
episode you know it's not like it's real
fight choreography or anything um and he
doesn't say much yeah second one's a lot
better the second one he does a bunch of
[__] well yeah like I said we'll kind of
get into like this one's good too I'm
not saying they're all good they're all
worth watching Christopher Lee I would
watch him read the [__] phone book
you know what I mean um because he's
just like cool and everything and he
always like classes up the joint but
like I said I kind of wish he'd been in
it more so this for they are actually
following I know that the hammer Dracula
movies they followed a loose
timeline sort of um you know in the
first few films but I kind of feel like
what's she doing tearing up your boots
oh she tearing up my boots stop it poy
she's like but what I want to tear up Bo
she like it's just just shoes yeah just
shoes you don't you don't need these
kitties don't have shoes but um she's
like now she's mad but yeah so uh from
the last one cuz like I said we didn't
see Dracula Prince of Darkness which is
the third one the one before this one so
evidently what happened at the end of
that one then I've seen it a long time
ago but I don't really remember but he's
like thrown off I think he's thrown into
like a river and it freezes over cuz I
think they established kind of early on
in the in the lore that Dracula was like
one of his weaknesses was running water
which that does not I mean that's not
totally pulled out of people's asses
that is a a Trope that like evil people
like evil people or evil beings or
whatever can't cross running water like
that's a pretty common thing so I guess
they kind of established that earlier on
in the lore so I guess at the end of
Dracula Prince of Darkness he got thrown
into into a river or something like that
and he froze so he's Frozen at the
beginning of this one now this one we
couldn't figure out what year it was set
but we figured it was like early 20th
century and I will say I looked it up
and you were correct it is actually set
in 1905 that's when it's supposed to be
set cuz I was looking at the clothes and
stuff and I said well this is that it's
it's more than late 19th century this is
early 20th century so this is supposed
to be set a year after Dracula Prince of
Darkness and Dracula's ass has been
frozen up there in the mountain all this
time like from the
River but it seems like the towns folk
are still like not really over it like
over this whole uh you know reign of
terror that Dracula did over the village
because they're like oh well the
Castle's still up there and its shadow
still touches the church like you can
still feel the evil or whatever so it's
like everybody stopped going to church
the Sad Sack bald ass priest that his
who has his hair I was just kind of like
oh my God please tell me that's a wig
that that's not real hair cuz it was
just I mean I guess it's a priest thing
where they just it almost looked like a
monk's toner or whatever they call that
where it was like empty in the middle
and then it's like there was all this
gray situation like down here like this
but he's you know what and I didn't even
realized this until I was watching
another review I don't even think they
even gave that [__] priest a name he
was just the priest yeah like in the
village and he's just become this
[__] sad sack I don't even believe in
God anymore man I just like sit in the
pub and like [__] drink my sorrows
away because nobody shows up to the
church because everyone is weirded out
still even though Dracula is supposedly
dead or he's Frozen or whatever so then
this mon Senior comes to town and he's
like why the [__] isn't anybody at
church you know because he's like super
getting all up in everyone's business
and everything and they're and they kind
of explained him why it's like yeah but
the vampire is dead what the [__] are
you worried about you know he's like
I'll tell you what I'm going to take my
giant brass balls up there and I'm going
to exercise the castle and then
everything will be totally fine and he's
like and you have to come with me priest
whatever your name is and he's like I'd
really rather not but you know what I
mean but they go up there anyway so
there's this kind of long sequence where
the monor and the priest are like
climbing up this mountain they I was
looking at him like they didn't have
hiking boots they didn't have protein
bars they didn't have like water bottles
or nothing I'm just like what the [__]
were you even planting so they're
climbing up this mountain and the mon
sior gets up there well the priest has
to like dip out because he's just kind
of like I can't make it I can't make it
he's like all right [__] you just like
stay here and I'm going to go the rest
of the way and do this [__] cuz
obviously you are useless so he goes up
there he does the blah blah blah and
like the exorcism and everything on the
castle and then he takes his big [__]
gold crucifix cross thing and like
sticks it in the door handle so while
he's up there doing that [__] the little
bald ass priest Who's down here being
all weak sauce he doesn't he like fall
or something like how does that H how
does that even happen like I think
trying to climb back down like to go
back down to the village and he's like
oh [__] I don't remember and then he
falls and then he his blood comes out
his mouth and like trickles down the
mountain like right into Christopher
Lee's mouth like there's like a crack in
the ice and I was like well that was 4
two it is yeah I remember that I mean
it's not yeah it's not the most
believable way for the vampire to be
brought back but like well I kind of
feel like every single Hammer Dracula
and I'm not [__] on it cuz I [__]
love Hammer movies I will watch them all
day long and I love Christopher Lee and
I love his Dracula
but it's like they I feel like the
writers were just kind of like okay well
every single movie has to be well
Dracula has to get resurrected at the
beginning obviously and then at the end
he always has to get destroyed but so
they always had to come up with like
ways for him to get brought back like at
the beginning of the movie so this one
he was like encased in ice and like this
dude's blood went in his mouth and he
was just like oh I'm awake now and he
like busts out the ice and you know
starts going on a [__] rampage again
and now this one has has okay this one
has the Roger dalry looking [__]
in it right who's Roger oh yeah Roger
the guy that looks like Roger dalry from
the hill yeah yeah and I'm glad to say
that I'm Not Who Roger do was I'm not
the only person that real that like
noticed that because I saw at least
three other reviewers that said this
Roger alter like a [__] yeah but
um he's the guy he's the ladies man
right well no this was that was the next
one that was the next one yeah but the
thing about it is that both
here's another thing that's confusing
and this is another kind of running joke
with like a lot of the hammer Dracula
movies the protagonist in this one who
looks like Roger doter with the perm and
everything yeah and has running around
with his no shirt on all the time that's
right his name is Paul and worked at the
bakery right yeah yeah the bakery dude
yeah and the protagonist like the the
mans [__] protagonist like in the in
scars of Dracula is also named Paul why
the [__] was everybody named Paul in
these movies and said that was kind of
the running joke too it's like
everybody's named Paul or Simon or Sarah
in these [__] movies it's like they
couldn't even come up with British were
like it they're just like yeah so both
of the protagonists in both these movies
are named Paul even though they're
completely different characters so yeah
it's the guy that works in the bakery
and okay so Dracula's Mission this time
around he goes up to his castle obvious
as he would he's like oh I'm awake now
so he goes back to his castle and he
sees that big [__] cross in there and
he's like [__] and he's like
really mad about it so then he's like
I'm going to take revenge but he's not
going to take Revenge by like killing
the mon senor the one who did it um he's
actually going to make the mon senior's
niece one of his Brides I'm presuming
like I think like CU he thinks that will
be like a better Revenge I guess so so
that's kind of the whole thing so you
have Paul the bakery guy who looks like
Roger do and he is now I kind of liked
this they made him an
atheist um and he's very like open about
it and he is courting the niece of the
monor who is in Dracula sits or whatever
so he and he goes to their house for
dinner and he's like not a jerk about it
or anything like that but the manor asks
him and he's just like oh you know I'm
an atheist like I said he's not like a
[__] about it or anything like that and
the monor's like get out of my house
blah and he's just like flips out but I
like that they had that Trope even
though of course like at the end he's
like oh yeah I had to you know find my
faith to fight the Dracula or whatever
but I like that they kind of made him
and they made him like a good like
heroic character yeah well the priest
ended up going like you know he's he's
still a good man type of deal yeah yeah
yeah and I and I liked that they that
they did that even though he's a filthy
non-believer you know what I mean like
he was still like a good dude and he
like did come around at the end it's
just like oh well he you know loves my
niece and he's going to help save her
now in the midst of all this brewhaha
Dracula makes the the first the the lame
ass priest that couldn't even make it
all the way up the mountain makes him
into like essentially a thrall so how he
finds out all this information about who
[__] up his castle and you know who
the niece is and all this other kind of
[__] so that's pretty much like what the
whole plot is is the Dracula trying to
get oh and he also makes a thall out of
the big tittied barid lady yeah Zena
yeah right cuz yeah cuz I made a joke
about it was like Zena Warrior Princess
and that's and that's another thing too
is that she kind of she gets made into I
guess she's a thw she had fangs at the
end but I don't know she was kind of
willing them yeah that's what I mean she
was kind of into it like you know I'm
not going to lie like Christopher Lee
comes in there he like hey I'm going to
make you a vampire I'm like okay I'm on
board but like so she was just kind of
like yeah all right but then she was mad
when he found out or when she found out
that he was after the niece yeah she got
jealous yeah because I think he was just
using the barid because the barid like
worked in the same place they set the
bar maid up as being a [__] yeah a
little bit okay basically she's trying
to [__] all these dudes well she was
trying to put the moves on Paul cuz he
got super drunk remember in the pub yeah
then she's like oh I'll take you
upstairs to the room and then she's like
oh I can just like take your pants off
and all stuff even though she she knew
that he had a girlfriend she's hot and
everything yeah and um but she ends up
seeing she ends up seeing Dracula and
she's like oh hell yeah she's impressed
with him so later on she he's doing
stuff to her you know he's biting her
he's changing her I think she did have
she got Little Fangs at times didn't she
yeah she had fangs like at the end when
they right well she ends up finding out
that he doesn't even like her he likes
the blonde he was just using her to get
at the other girl she and she got
furious with his ass she's like what the
hell you going after her for you got me
you know and she she stood up for
herself he killed her well yeah yeah for
that yeah which I was like
man they're just they just had to get a
body count in the movie is what I mean
it's a horror movie you got to see
people get kill had I don't think that
was a good way to kill her um I would
think that U that an experienced vampire
would know how to deal with that in a
better way an experienced vampire yeah
cuz Hey man he'd have a whole Rolodex
full of Undead house I have 500 years
experience as a vampire and I know what
I'm doing yeah and I got a her on of
[__] 30 vampire women you know and so
you you would think that he would have
all different kinds of women in his uh
in his role of day
you know in his stable and uh I'm sure
that over the years he'd find out you
know how useful a woman like this would
be you know what I mean especially since
she was like so into it she she was like
into him even even not didn't matter
that he was turning into a vampire she
was into it before yeah she's just yeah
she was all about it yeah she just kind
of like hey you're the only interesting
man in this Village
yeah so you know I just thought it was
kind of like a cheap blow to where he
just gets mad like oh don't you back
talk me and he kills her yeah po yeah
yeah sure he can make another one
but a willing one would be would be more
valuable than one that you just
turned yeah because well and that's kind
and they kind of show that a little bit
maybe not maybe they didn't mean to but
what ends up happening is that she's
kind of a thw and the priest is kind of
a thw but the priest is not super
willing like yeah he lost his faith and
yeah he's like oh I can't do anything
about it and he's like self-hating and
all that kind of stuff so he's just is
kind of doing the bidding but he's still
kind of conflicted about it like he
still kind of doesn't want to do it and
like the fact that Dracula makes him
like after he kills Zena he tells the
priest hey get rid of her like and he
throws her in the big like Bakery oven
big Bakery oven like the fire and stuff
and I think like the more that he made
the priest do [__] up [__] that was
how he was able to kind of like get to
the end and be like man I can't [__]
do this anymore you know what I mean so
he still had some of his faith in most
Vamp in most vampire stories the the
male
THS the ones that they keep around are
willing to like uh Renfield was was kind
of willing and if you read between the
lines you know it's be it's because he
had promised Renfield ever you know
everlasting life in as the
undead so that's one way you could get a
guy to serve you right promise him
promise to make him a
vampire but instead you've only you give
him a little bit he's not really a
vampire he's a real weak one yeah so
you're just a half ass vampire yeah but
you know they need those THS to help
them do their [__] well yeah you need
somebody that can walk around in the
daytime and do regular human being [__]
yeah you know what I mean so you know
what I mean I just was kind of like
what'd he kill her for he could have
kept that going for a long long time
maybe he just thought it was too much to
deal with he's like I don't want to deal
with this like [__] issue cuz like I
said his whole like I said it's not like
a super believable but at least in
Dracula in this one he had like a
mission his whole mission was he was
going to [__] with the mon sior who
killed him exercised no he didn't kill
him he exercised his castle he exercised
his castle so he couldn't live in it
anymore that's right that's right um so
he was mad about he didn't put him in
the ice though no no no that that was
from the last movie as far as I know
okay I was cuz I didn't see Dracula I
was under the impression that he also
like destroyed him in the movie before
but I don't think he did though because
he didn't really know what was going on
so much like when he came to the pub cuz
he was like or I don't know maybe that
same guy wasn't Dracula Prince of
Darkness I'm not sure like I said we
were going to watch that one but I
couldn't really find it so I don't know
what happened at the end of that I don't
know if he was the one that like put him
in the ice or what so what I mean if
that was the case then that would you
know make it more that he was like oh I
know why he's mad but I mean he's still
mad because he's like this [__]
came up here and put this big [__]
cross at my door and now I can't get in
my [__] house so you know he was mad
about that and like I said the so he
decided he was going to take Maria his
virginal niece or whoever and make her
into a bride because he thought that
that would be like an ultimate [__] you
you know what I mean so the thing about
it so when they have this big battle
with Dracula at the end so you have Paul
or Roger dalry as I call him so you have
Roger dalry
and the Roger adultery clone and um the
priest who finally like snaps out of his
thrw or whatever the problem though and
I okay so I I wasn't sure how this
worked so they actually
did like they go to his like Dracula's
little Lair or whatever and they stake
him but I don't know okay so when did
they establish the fact that you have to
not only stake them but you have to like
pray over it too cuz I thought you could
just stake them and one and die you know
what I mean but so yeah so the fact add
yeah that's what I'm saying so the fact
that they staked him but because Paul
was an atheist so his prayers don't work
apparently and because the priest had
lost his faith and was also kind of a
vampire thrall his prayers didn't work
either so the staking didn't
take right I guess so yeah so I was just
kind of like well how does that work I
don't know I thought you just staked him
and that was fine but no so he come so
Dracula gets up and he's just like H and
he just like pulls the [__] steak out
and so then he like takes and you know
then they have to like go [__] fight
him and stuff now here's the thing so
again like the big battle to end Dracula
always has to be destroyed so they're
fighting on this roof or whatever and
Paul who is you know he looked like a
pretty fit dude but he was probably like
150 PBS soaking wet and that's being
generous yeah he is able
to um kind of like cuz what ends up
happening is Maria earlier she takes the
cross off the door and like throws it
off the cliff and it like lands face up
conveniently like with the with the
pointy bit up and so then they're so
Paul and Dracula are like fighting on
the roof and Paul is somehow able to
like Yeet Dracula off the castle wall
and he lands and like gets staked which
is a great scene by the way I really do
like like cuz Christopher Lee is down
there this big [__] cross like
sticking out of and he's just like oh
[__] you know what I mean it's like and
it's really good it's really well done
but I was like I don't know if I believe
that that little Paul dude could just
Chuck a powerful vampire off a roof yeah
you know at 150 155 lbs I mean he's kind
of shredded but he didn't have much mass
yeah that yeah he was in good shape I'm
not saying that cuz like I said they did
show him shirtless a bunch of times so
he was like in good shape yeah they
wanted you to see that he shed yeah he's
like look but he he wasn't big though
right and I mean Dracula is a
supernatural
being with superum strength so I would
just think You' just push him and it
would just be like he it would be like a
[__] concrete AB butman or something
I would have this movie seemed like it
was older than it really was if it
seemed like it was an old movie The
Other One seemed a lot more more fresh
there's something about it it was and
there were only a couple of years
between those two the writing was
better yeah like I said it's weird
because I kind of feel like people like
the perception is that people people
tend to like this movie better than than
scars of Dracula but I well I like scars
of Dracula more because of how lurd it
was I think the reason why they're
liking this one is because it's it seems
like an old
1930s uh Universal picture yeah you know
from uh Universal monster movie that's
what it seems like it's like they're
aping that style but it's in color yeah
well that was kind of the idea from the
from the get like you know when Hammer
was doing these they're like well we
want to take the classic movie Monsters
or like bring them to the modern era
like with more tits and more blood and
which like I mean they were bloody for
the time I mean wasn't that big of a
difference though yeah not really not at
this point but I guess a lot it would
have seemed like more of a difference
back then I guess later they got a lot
better yeah like uh Carmela was real
good um the the the one after this scars
of Dracula I thought that was real good
yeah it was actually two after this
I think after this one was Taste the
Blood of Dracula and then it was scars
of Dracula and then I think it was ad1
1972 I think they're getting more
violent more sadistic more sexual and I
think scars of Dracula is the
most um is the most gory cuz I was
actually surprised at how gory it was
and like I said Hammer movies they tend
to be like bloodier than obviously like
the universal monster movies but scars
of Dracula actually surprise me at how
how um violent it was and I think that
that's something that a lot of people
bring up that it's just kind of like man
they just went like so over the top of
it but I didn't mind that I thought that
was actually pretty good because I like
that kind of [__] but you know what I
mean I want to say something that they
did in this one too which I just kind of
wanted to point out um that I think like
Freddy Francis directed this like I said
he did a lot of hammer movies he did
some Amicus movies as well and he used
these weird filters like color filters
so sometimes in some of the shots
there's like a weird like vignette
effect like around the edges of the
frame that are like colored that are
like yellow or Amber or kind of red or
something like that and it's really
interesting like it's not really on they
wasn't they didn't really do that in any
of the other movies and I guess he just
wanted to to do that I I think they were
the same filters they used for the
Innocence but that was in black and
white yeah you know what I mean so so it
looks really strange but also kind of
interesting cuz a couple shots in this I
was like man that kind of looks like a
goo film like look at that like
saturation like around the edges of the
frame and then when I looked it up they
said yeah he had these like filters that
in between watching these two movies we
caught a little bit of a documentary
about Hammer films yeah I got to finish
watch I got to finish watch it was
pretty good we saw about 20 30 I mean
it's old but um you know but I was I
thought it was like really interesting I
didn't realize that
that they were so big but then went went
back off into a obscurity What in in a
period of about 15 years 20 years yeah I
mean they're hat wer around well well no
they were around from uh 1930s 1940s oh
was it right but they didn't really I
mean they're most famous for their
horror movies and they didn't really
start those until like the 50s yeah okay
you know what I mean they made other
kind well they made other kind of movies
to that period was only lasted about 20
years I think they said by the time the
70s came around and like I said we'll
talk about that in a second cuz when we
talk about scars of Dracula by the time
scars of Dracula and like the later
Dracula movies were coming out Hammer
was kind of on the decline yeah now
Hammer still they did a Revival they're
still around nowadays um and they still
make some horror movies they make some
other things too but they made like cuz
they made um The Woman in Black like the
one with Daniel Radcliffe which was
actually pretty decent and um you know
they they made a couple of other ones
since then I mean it's nothing like it
was back then but you know so um so yeah
so honest honestly yeah so I liked this
movie I lik this movie a lot um I liked
the characters but it did seem
especially in comparison with scars of
Dracula which like I said a lot of
people you know it's kind of like the
most disparaged one of the series I feel
like but I kind of liked that one for
how brutal it was I mean at least in
relation to like the other ones you know
what I'm saying taste change sure yeah I
like this one I like scars and Dracula
better I did as well I know and like I
like that might be cuz it had a it it
was it was a new take on things yeah
they're showing you more details about
what Dracula's doing behind the [__]
scenes it's more about Dracula yeah
they're showing you how he slept which
is pretty [__] cool yeah we we need
to get and it was just right out of Anne
Rice I know an rice saw this movie
probably though yeah yeah well I think
she saw all all Dracula and vampire
movies that she could get her hands on
but
um and this one Dracula has a in his
castle he's he sleeps in a in a room
that there's no way to get into from
inside the castle it's it's all totally
walled off but that room has a window
and it's all Stone it you know where his
sarcophagus is you know his [__]
coffin there's a window in there and the
window's overlooking a sheer Cliff where
he just gets out and walks out and walks
up the wall yeah cuz he and goes into
the floor above it and that's how he
gets in so you nobody else can nobody
else can get in there unless you got
like some [__] rope and you you know
where it is mountain climbing [__] and
uh that was that that was some cool [__]
that was one of the things that was
really cool about an rice vampire
Chronicles cuz they she'd let you in on
all the details of how vampires lived
and yeah you could live in a normal
house for a little while but that long
term you couldn't live in there cuz the
house could burn down they could you
know humans could get in there and find
out where you
sleep if a vampire wanted to live a long
time he had to have a hidden vault where
he
slept like Magnus had one where he just
would pull a stone out of a wall in an
old abanded castle and there was a
tunnel he'd get in there and on the
other side of that stone there was a
little broad iron ring and it he put his
foot in there and drag it in behind him
and it was you know hundreds and
hundreds of pounds a human couldn't move
it and then he'd walk or he'd crawl it's
a single a was a it's a Channel or a
tunnel size of a single
Stone you go 30 or 40 feet and it would
open up into just a vault that had had
the coffin and there was no way in or
out of there you know sealing yourself
up at night and it was impervious to
fire which is very clever yeah you
couldn't burn a castle that was Stone
well that the same thing in this one
Dracula's Tammy said Spider-Man could
get in Spider-Man get that's right fair
enough yeah well I was going he must
turn into a bat fly out but no he just
fing went climb the wall well I really
like that they did cuz Leslie just
mentioned that it's like it's very cool
Christopher Lee climbing the castle wall
and scars yeah because honestly that was
one of the things that I loved the most
from the novel was like Dracula like
climbing down the wall like a [__]
bug I thought that was so cool like that
image and they don't put it in a lot of
movies matter of fact what I heard about
scars of Dracula is that the um director
of this which was Ro Roy Ward Baker um
who directed A a [__] ton of stuff but
he very specifically wanted to put a
shot of Dracula climbing down the wall
and the production people were like no
we can't afford that because this I'll
get into it in a little bit but this
movie had like a lot lower budget than
most of the previous didn't seem like it
but um but yeah so they were like yeah
we can't afford that but he like
insisted he really wanted that in there
oh that's a great shot because yeah
because it's like it and Christopher Lee
and you know this is not a secret either
but Christopher Lee kind of felt a
little bit um you know the more that he
had to play the character he was mad
that it was getting more and more away
from the character from the novel like
he wanted to get back more into like the
classic Dracula thing so you know
putting things like that from the that
were from the novel like him climbing
down the wall and um you know kind of
having Dracula in this would be more of
a character like you know and people
coming to his house and him like hosting
them and giving them wine stuff like
that like I feel like that was more
along the lines of what he was talking
about yeah you know yeah and he had some
fine vampire girlfriends but once again
he kills him which which yeah that holy
crap yeah which I guess makes him I
guess makes him more menacing really
villainous yeah we're like dude man he
did some [__] up [__] she did cheat on
him she cheated on him yeah we'll get it
done but when she when she tried to
drink that dude or was she actually
trying to escape I don't know that's
yeah they didn't really make that I
think she was a vampire I think she was
trying to trying to trying to drink that
guy but but uh drink him like a son but
uh Dracula saw it his infidelity he
killed her killed her with a knife too
stabbing her he was almost kind of like
[__] you're not even worth biting yeah
I'm just going to stab you right in your
[__] yeah and then left her there
left her dead in the bed well he left
her there and then he made his lacky
[__] [__] dismember her and like
throw her in acid or something it's like
it's pretty [__] up they threw her in
water and she boiled boiled away I think
it was supposed to be suppos to be I
think it supposed to be acid like when I
looked it up later I was like oh yeah
maybe she wasn't totally turned into a
vampire yeah I'm not real clear on like
the rules of how that was she was fine
though she was yeah she was fine and
they didn't use her for very long in the
movie yeah was her name Tanya right yeah
that was her name yeah but yeah so so
this one scars of Dracula okay so there
was a movie in between these two that we
didn't see that was Taste the Blood of
Dracula which we'll have to get into a
little bit good um but this one scars of
Dracula okay so hammer put out four
count them four vampire movies in 1970
which is when this one came out two of
them on Christopher Lee in them the
other two did not I think they also put
out the vampire lovers and I can't lust
for a vampire I think was the other one
but yeah so four [__] vampire movies
so like I said at this point Hammer was
kind of starting to like they were on
the decline a little bit and right
before scars of Dracula came out or
while it was in production or whatever
they actually lost their deal with their
American Distributors so I think that
they were going with I think it was Emi
that they were going with at this point
and so the budget for this one was cut
like prodigiously they didn't really get
a lot of the budget that they would
normally get for a movie like this so
some people have said that the effects
in this like look notably cheaper um
which I didn't notice it so much now the
matte paintings look very obviously like
matte paintings and Miniatures uh so
there is that but they look stylish to
me but yeah it didn't really like other
than that it didn't really like smack me
in the face it looking like a lot
cheaper but a lot of people have have
complained that this one looks a lot
cheaper than the other ones which maybe
it does but I didn't see a huge the
story makes up for it man yeah and like
I said the the fact that I was actually
shocked by how [__] up some of the
stuff that happens in this is like it
kind of made up for a lot of stuff you
know so yeah so this one with the first
one like I said they did have some kind
of loose continuity with these Dracula
movies this one kind of breaks the
continuity a little bit cuz at the
beginning you know obviously Dracula is
dead because he's dead at the beginning
of everyone and he has to be resurrected
and he is like these red ashes now he
did apparently get turned into red ashes
at the end of taste Taste of Blood of
Dracula but it happened in
London and this one is not in London
this one is
in an imaginary Eastern European vaguely
area I think
it's yeah it's supposed to be like
Transylvania with his castle or whatever
and there's a mysterious bat yeah so how
he gets resurrected in this one and this
is not really explained never was I
thought they were the whole time we were
like are they going to explain this or
no okay they never do explain it spoiler
alert but yeah so at the very beginning
now that's the one thing I like about
this one though because like um in
Dracula's risen from the grave it takes
a while for Dracula to actually get
risen from the then it wasn't a grave it
was a frozen thing block it was like a
block of ice okay but we're not going to
quibble but it took a while for that to
happen like it was like half an hour
into the movie or something like that
like before he even got up and started
running around this one he's resurrected
immediately like in the pre-credit
sequence and I was on board with that
yeah it looked cool so he's in his uh
room which they don't show you you can't
access until later you know what I mean
but he's in his room in his coffin or
whatever and this bat this very
obviously fake bat but it's like the bat
flies in the window fake bat comes in
Bat flies in the window and like
dribbles blood on him like in his mouth
on his dust yeah on his red dust cuz
he's just a red dust with a cape yeah
and this like causes him to re grow he
grows like he grows back like bones up
and he has clothes and everything yeah
and it's old school effect but it looked
cool yeah it was like a dissolve like
from a skeleton like up to so we're like
oh so a vampire another vampire helped
him see that's what I I was like who is
that bat yeah and the bat you see the
bat throughout the whole movie appear
but I guess it's Dracula in his Bat form
but it's that same prop that they used
so you think it's another vampire I did
I thought it was another vampire helping
him I thought it was too but no it
wasn't so we don't know who the first
bat
was that first bat it was they can't be
Dracula because he can't bring his own
ass back to life can and then all the
other bats are Dracula but that's the
same [__] rubber bat
yeah just some random bat that was just
and they they could have they could have
easily [__] um they could have easily
explained
it t they chose not to yeah see that's
what I thought when she was introduced I
was like oh she must be the bat the bat
right like that's his girlfriend that's
his vampire bride and she was like oh
I'll wake you up M they could had it so
Tanya so she was the bat had a vial of
his blood to bring him back to life in
case anything ever happens to him and
why are you not not a screener they need
to make me write this [__] not to write
it WR I mean that's all you needed was
like one line and then you know all you
needed after that is have a scene where
he [__] thanks her you know what I
mean for or rewards her for following
his instructions bring back in case any
bad [__] ever written in case I ever get
like reduced ashes this is what I need
and then he could he could have bit his
own arm like that and dribbled it into a
damn vile and screwed it shut he goes
just in case it happens again here's
more yeah yeah yeah here's more of my
blood which hey that's another and there
you go man you get another movie out of
that sure you can get another movie out
of that even if you kill Tanya you can
still say well that vile was still
[__] around right so if somebody
finds that they found it yeah I mean
honestly all you had to do in the first
or second movie was you could set up
Dracula being like man I'm going to my
[__] ass is going to live forever and
he just fills up all these vials and
then like he's got a whole bunch of them
like in a well you wouldn't have a
refrigerator back then but you know what
I'm saying you'd have like a bunch of
the vials and so you'd always have some
like way for him to be brought by you
could have your army your Gypsy Army of
mercenaries you give them some vials in
case I ever die you know what I mean
[__] you can find my body and bring
me back and I'll give you a mountain of
gold that you know then you know then
the Gypsy can bring it back all
different ways you could do exactly give
it to THS right you know what I mean
find my my body and pour this on it and
I'll come back yeah you like give him a
coded message or something like that
just some Rando didn't
yeah the whole time like the that came
in we were like intrigued like the whole
time like who is this bat and we thought
we were going to like figure out like
who the bat was but they never and then
like I said when Tanya showed up I was
just kind of like oh she's the bat but I
guess she's not the bat cuz I didn't
know if she was a full vampire or not
but yeah but I don't know but like I
said I'll get into I don't know the
rules about being a thrw and stuff so so
this mysterious bat brings him back to
life and immediately you know he's
Dracula so he's going to start like
drinking some [__] right so he does
that to one woman and the villagers are
just I mean outraged as they would be
the the guy like brings his daughter
into the church he's like look what
happened like this [__] dra with this
Dracula we killed him and now he's back
or whatever so and again this is like
this movie like pretty much front loads
it with like cool [__] because minutes
into the movie you know Dracula's
already killed the lady you don't see it
it's like off screen but she just he
just the dad carries her in to the
church and it's like look at this is
[__] up all the villagers like and
they just like immediately all go get
tortes we're going to burn that [__]
[__] down and they go and burn his
[__] Castle down like five minutes
into the movie it's literally like five
minutes yeah but the thrw says fire
you'll fire will never reach him yeah
and which yeah he he thought of that he
had his special vampire safe room yeah
couldn't burn it down so they're just
kind of like bring it [__] I think it
just burned it just burned the roof off
of it and some other places cuz he was
living he was back in it living he was
living in part of it living in part of
it it looked didn't burn it off it
wasn't real clear because like I said
the castle that they showed was either a
mat painting or a miniature so it wasn't
real clear like where in the castle he
was living or where his coffin was like
on that wall because I'm sitting there
going well where would it be cuz it
looked like the top of the castle was
like all burned off I thought you know
what I mean from the map painting or
whatever so it's just just kind of like
I thought he was like in another
building somewhere like haha [__] I'm
like hiding over here I thought it was
that kind of thing so so that happens oh
I also have to say the dude that plays
his thall in this one like his servant
who is named clove now I think in
Dracula Prince of Darkness which I
haven't seen since I was a teenager but
he also had a servant named clove in
that one like with a K but it was a
different actor and it was clearly a
different character so
I'm not really sure why they reuse the
name again but whatever so this guy
who's played by the same dude that
played the priest and The Omen that got
[__] yeah impaled yeah like he was in
a million other things too but that's
what I remembered him from I'm like oh
my God it's the priest from The Omen but
yeah so he's in this and he's got like
some crazy [__] eyebrows man oh my
God the they added eyebrows to they
added eyebrows on and I was just like
the eyebrows are like a separate entity
man they were just kind of it was a
whole vibe that was he looks like a
gorilla in it he does and like he's
great I like him though like he's
totally like chewing the scenery but I
was into it so he's um so he's the
servant and yeah he says to the
villagers and burn it all you want like
you know you'll never get to him so
there's that so while all of that is
going on there's also all of our regular
young people characters like you usually
have in these movies now this is the one
this dude's name is also Paul and he is
a man [__] at the
we find him he is [__] the who the
burgo Meister the burger Meister burgo
Meister yeah burgo Meister his daughter
yeah he's [__] her yeah she's hot and
he also has another girlfriend or
something and he's just like oh I'm
supposed to go to this other
girlfriend's but I don't know I'll get
to this later but I'm not sure if that
other girl is his girlfriend or it's his
brother's girlfriend I don't really get
it but I think they supposedly like at
the first time like tried to set up this
love triangle but I think it didn't
really play out like the way they
thought because it was like so many cuts
and everything something that they
dropped yeah I think they dropped it
eventually because originally I thought
that she was like oh I kind of like both
the brothers and I'm [__] both of
them and I'm going to marry one of them
but I can't decide which one I don't
know I thought it was that but then they
didn't really do anything with it but
we'll get into that later so so this
Paul is [__] the bergo meister's
daughter and they get caught like bergo
Meer comes home in his outfit with all
the feathers and and pimp and gold and
everything and he sees her and she just
like totally like run around like comes
down the stairs like all naked and [__]
and she's like I'm like that's a little
weird yeah and then she straight up this
[__] hussy yeah she's mad because
Paul is like oh I got to go and she's
like you're going to see another girl
which he is and he's like no I'm totally
not I have to go to this other like not
not other girl thing and so but she
doesn't believe it and so she straight
up accuses her like cuz he's leaving and
she's naked and so the dad comes and
just like what's the meaning of this and
all other [__] and then like she's like
he interfered with me she says straight
up accused him of rape right and he's
just like gotta go so he's like so he
blew over though that was the funny
thing he put him in jail well he
basically had to go to like the next
town over like to avoid being like
picked up by the authorities that's
right they were looking for him they
were looking for him still so so yeah so
that's how he kind of ended up because
he actually is running away from the law
and he ends up at this Inn that's kind
of right by the Dracula castle and it's
after dark and they don't want to let
him in and that also has like a hot
barid who is just kind of like oh okay
I'll let you in and then they just start
making out like immediately because he's
a [__] player yeah this [__] dude
yeah he just like he every single time
like he sees a woman he's like yeah I'm
going to and she's just like okay yeah
and if they're hot then they just fall
right into hand he has like he's just
has like a magic dick I guess it's a
magic dick yeah
so anyways that's where he meets that
hot blonde hussy she wasn't blonde
though she was she was darkhair wasn't
yeah she was she was dark yeah the
blonde was in the in the other movie
yeah well this has a blonde in it too
but the blonde is his is his brother
brother's girlfriend girlfriend but like
I said I thought it was kind of his
girlfriend too at the time but it's like
that didn't really work out in well he
shows up at this end and they won't let
and and she's not supposed to let him in
because they're afraid of the damn
vampire right uh so her boss com they
end up kicking him out after they were
almost making out she was almost well
they were kind of making out cuz he was
just kind of like hey I'm just know she
was going to take him up to her bed and
she we don't have any beds available you
sleep with me you don't have any rooms
available and he's like well how about a
bed and she's like and this [__]
happened in like within two minutes and
I'm like this is a trap this didn't
happen this is a trap dude that's what I
said this dude this doesn't happen like
this man this like a like a like a a a
woman that was not that it was not a
Serial ker or aute is not going to be
like hey come like within like seconds
well it's three things she's a serial
killer or she's the front for a [__]
for for a um for a mugger she going to
get you somewhere they're going to mug
you or she's a hooker yeah you know
those are the only three possibilities
that that [__] where a woman is just
kind of like yeah I'll jump on a
stranger's dick that only happens in
porn yeah that never happens in real
life it yeah it does well that very that
very rarely rare here it's a lot more
common in South America well yeah but
I'm just talking they're professional
girls it's just yeah if it's too easy
it's going to cost
you you know you may not be able to
afford it depending on how much money
you got so no that's I was watching a
review of this earlier like I if you
guys are not subscribed to grumpy
Andrew's horror house I love him he's a
British dude and um he does all and he
loves all these Hammer movies and stuff
like that and I was watching his review
of this earlier and he said this part of
the movie like plays out almost like a
British sex comedy which it kind of does
because Paul is just kind of like
constantly you know falling into these
women's vaginas and then like having to
like climb out of Windows to like Escape
Justice stuff like it's not I don't want
to oversell it like it's not zany or
Benny Hill or anything but it does have
that kind of like British sex farce vibe
to it so he gets kicked out of the in so
he runs up he goes well I'm going to go
up to the castle maybe they're they and
they're just like yeah they're like he's
just like maybe be nicer up there so he
goes up there and he knocks on the door
beautiful woman lets him in comes and
gets him and that was Tanya yeah Tanya
lets him in and then Dracula comes up
and meets him and they give him [__]
wine and [__] tell he can stay and and
it was pretty cool you know what I mean
like okay this is this is a [__]
vampire movie this is what I was paying
to see well like I said it's kind of
like the novel where Dracula's like a
host yeah you didn't really see that in
a lot of the hammer movies he you
know he's being track Ula and doing
Dracula type stuff doing Dracula things
and uh they give him a
room and he's in there looking for his
brother cuz he thinks his brother ended
up in there no no no this is the this is
the first guy the first guy that's right
we we haven't got to the brother yet
yeah yeah the brother that's right the
brother comes looking for him later the
brother Simon looking for right that's
right got confused and uh they give him
a
room and uh [__] what ended up happen
oh yeah Tanya comes comes in comes she
just Knocks room with her night stuff
like that yeah she comes in there fine
as hell and just throws herself at she
I'm a prisoner here you know they [__]
and everything yeah I guess they did
right direct yeah she says she's a
prisoner there and she's like oh I think
she she doesn't say that he's a vampire
though does she no yeah so I don't know
exactly if she was
gonna it sounded like she was going to
betray Dracula dra I they didn't make it
real clear over whether she said that
just because she wanted to drink him
yeah I wasn't I wasn't sure cuz she did
hit she did hit yeah I mean they they
[__] right but u i mean they didn't
show it but they implied very strongly
so I didn't know if she was just saying
that like to be like oh poor me like you
know what I mean like you know let's
[__] or if she was actually trying to
get him to help her Escape they never
really made that super clear yeah well
he wakes up Dracula's right there
overlooking the bed he just killing her
with a knife yeah he just like a [__]
straight up cereal kill man like right
in the stomach curve knife he's he's
jugging her
up and then he drinks out of her stomach
yeah I think he does yeah yeah he drinks
out of her stomach and I can't remember
what happened that's messed up he um
while this is going on they um Dracula
basically locks him in in that room yeah
he tries to escape he throws he makes a
rope out of uh out of the the curtains
and throws it out the window and tries
to make his way down that sheer Cliff
but there was no way he could make it
all the way to the bottom but he was
trying to make it to a place where there
was some these little rocks that you
could grab onto right and as he was
climbing down he found a
window open window didn't have glass or
anything just he goes in there and that
was that was uh drag the secret vault
yeah and he opens up the [__] casket
and sees
dragon and that's the last time you see
him you don't see that character until
later I forgot to mention because what
we were mentioning like [__] up [__]
happened in this movie like where he
just stabbed that woman in the stomach
and then drank blood out of her stomach
yeah like you're not even worth like
biting your neck like cuz that's like a
sexual thing and I don't even and I hate
you cuz you [__] me over something like
that I forgot that prior to this after
the villagers burned the castle down
yeah Dracula apparently sent all the
bats and killed all the women in the
village that's right that's right cuz
they go into the church and it looks
like a [__] slasher movie there's
dead women every there's blood
splattered all over the I was like holy
[__] there's woman with her eyeball
hanging out holy crap that's how he
punished that's how he punished the town
yeah so it's like I totally forgot so
that like shocked me like not it doesn't
shock me because like I said I've seen
way worse than that in horror movies but
not in a hammer movie I was just kind of
like holy crap they really like went for
broke on this one didn't they it's a
[__] blood bath after that happened
the dude's brother and his his wife
another fine one his yeah fiance
girlfriend something yeah she's kind of
you know she's this uh blonde cleavage
the whole nine yards but you know and
they go to the end and he that's where
he picks up the trail of his brother he
finds out yes they're looking because
they're like where is that [__]
they find out that they that he went
that he went to the castle Yeah so they
go to the castle now that brunette gets
attacked by Dracula and turned into a
damn uh you know the uh the scuzzy chick
that was she wasn't scuzzy but the
[__] chick that was working at the end
yeah she gets turned into a thrw and
she's all I don't know if I'd be calling
her [__] but she was um she was trying
to hit everything over eager yeah she
was trying to hit she was just trying to
hook up somebody but did end up helping
yeah um you know Simon and the and the
Bland blonde chick like when nobody else
would cuz everybody was like just get
out of here we don't want they were
trying they were trying to you know they
were trying to say that she was a hoe
though well I know but I'm just saying
that's that's why Dracula in the end
didn't like her he liked Purity Dracula
don't like hoes yeah he just yeah he
uses ho even though you think Dracula be
all about that you think he'd be all
about it or you'd think like I said have
a variety yeah that he'd just have a
today today I'm in a hoe kind of mood
yeah he's ho my good girls and this
where's my funny
girl that's that's actually how dra
would really be he have a Dracula yeah
he'd that's how a Dracula do yeah he
would have like a whole Fu a whole
panoply yeah he he he'd have a bunch of
De for once he' he'd have a fat girl a
pretty fat girl he'd have one of those
he have fat girls skinny girls tall
girls short girls he'd have a whole
collection yeah I mean well I mean you
would do that if you were a vampire all
all men will do that so that's what I'm
just go back in history and look at so
I'm just saying yeah any any dude that
any heterosexual man that would be made
into a vampire and was given given the
had the wherewithal to do that would or
was given the yeah or was allowed to do
that would would absolutely do that yeah
you would just have like a whole they
would have a whole Herm like I said
Thomas told me that he would have a Herm
if he was allowed yeah you're not
allowed though now
[Laughter]
give left to their own left to their own
device dudes do this um societies keep
them in they do but left left their own
devices they'll do it um and if you look
at human history men were polygamous the
more money you had the more power you
had the more women they had they would
have couple different wives and then
they'd have a whole bunch of damn
concubines and then party
girls you know and you know goes jenus
Khan had think about a thousand of them
you know um I think what was his name
Charlamagne had a bunch of them it's
just when left of their own in a
medieval type situations all the
hypergamy all the all the good-looking
girls of the town are going for the
noblemen they're not enough noblemen and
there's a [__] ton of good-look girls
they don't want
to date a
peasant well you if they're forced to
date a peasant they'll do it but you
know they they'll fool around with the
nobleman because they he can do
something for her you know so most of
those nobl men had a whole bunch of
women and well yeah like I said yeah cuz
you know women date over and up you know
they date they date up dudes date down
they don't have any problem with that
they'll prefer to date down they find it
attractive that's why a lot of those
really rich executive girls they women
they they can't really find mates the
guys that they are interested in are
going out with poor girls that work at D
Starbucks or something
true yeah so um so yeah okay so [__]
up [__] so not only does Dracula stab
Tanya in the stomach after he finds her
and has [__] the dude I don't know if
he was mad because she [__] the dude
or if she was mad because or if he was
mad because she was like oh she betrayed
me and like said um like said she wanted
to escape yeah like I said it's not
clear but it doesn't really matter so he
stabs her in the stomach drinks blood
out of her stomach like I said I was
like [__] up and then leaves her there
for old clove The Omen priest it's like
hey get rid of her and then clove cuts
her into
pieces and dissolves her pieces in acid
yeah so like I said this is kind of
Hardcore for a hammer movie yeah kind of
Hardcore yeah I did too but that's kind
of like why I was kind of into it so
yeah they also added the little plot
Trope or plot sideline of clove being
like falling in love with Sarah who's
Simon's uh love
interest um the blonde because they
always have a blonde and a brunette and
usually a red head I don't know was
there a red head in this one there was a
red head in the other one the the barid
was a red head yeah I don't think this
had a red but this one this one had a
blonde and a couple of brunette the
other barid was a red head yeah yeah
yeah and she was another want hussy yeah
yeah well you know they always said
those redheads you got to put you got to
put those kind of characters in a
British movie of this area era I'm a
natural redhead yeah so a take of that
you're not a natural hussy though I'm
not a natural hussy no no no am I a
learned hussy you're yeah you learned it
learn Hy it's [__] funny that's what
I start put I'm G to put that on my
business card yeah learned hussy learned
hussy this end up being a fun train
cougar but yeah so she so that happens
to her and then so they have this whole
thing of clove falling in love with
Sarah from the picture which was kind of
like the Francis Ford Copa thing with
Dracula seeing the picture and being
like Oh who's this babe you know what I
mean they kind of did that because um
you know Sarah had that picture of her
that somebody she had gotten for a
present or whatever and clove got a hold
of it somehow and then he fell in love
with the with the her just from the
picture like before he met her so then
there was like this whole thing where he
was um like torn in his allegiances like
between Dracula who was his master and
wanting to save this woman from her fate
you know what I mean because she was
like the virginal one who's you know the
one that always ends up like that
there's also a pretty [__] up scene
where Christopher Lee as Dracula cuz I
mean the reason this is called the
literally the only reason this is called
scars of Dracula is because and Dracula
doesn't have any scars so so he's
putting scars on people he's putting
scar well on one person in particular on
clove whenever clove does something that
makes him mad he what you think at first
that he's whipping him because he has
like all of these scars on his back but
what he's actually doing is he's heating
up this sword and like pressing it like
into the Flesh of his back like branding
him essentially so they do like have a
scene of that too and I was like man
that is messed up this is like pretty
messed up for a hammer movie like so so
say it's like kind of lurid but I was
kind of into that you know what I mean
cuz you don't usually see and I do like
the kind of more stayed Gothic um hammer
movies but I'm just saying seeing seeing
this kind of lured [__] like in this
context and like Christopher Lee doing
this stuff I was I don't know I was kind
of into it no it was cool I was kind of
into it they're just showing they're
just showing you a detailed account of
how how draa controls his THS and stuff
yeah what he does what he tells him and
I feel like um he's [__] he's [__]
sadistic yeah and like Christopher Lee
was like and he was like very he was a
lot more I'm not saying he wasn't sexual
in the other Dracula movies cuz he was
but I feel like he was more overtly
sexual in this one yeah you know what I
mean in the sense of like coming in
people's rooms and being like hey and
they're like hey you know what I mean
and him being like yeah they're like
making out and [__] so yeah he's not
good to his women either well no no he's
a dick yeah he's a like he's a a real
villain in this one like a real V you
know Dracula's obviously a villain he
just like drinks people but you know
what I mean like in this one he just
like does like really cool [__] which is
crazy um also they introduce as far as I
know this is the first time they
introduce this in a movie but it's like
where Dracula can even see when he's
sleeping because like his eyes glow red
like even through his eyelids he can see
you through he can see you he can see
you through his
eyelids like that's you know the special
effect is kind of cheesy but I was like
yeah like I didn't mind it I didn't mind
it so yeah so there was this whole
[__] thing about um you know the
brother of the manor like coming to look
for him and you know that something bad
happened to that dude but they don't
show you what happened to him until like
later cuz we're sitting there going what
the [__] happened to that dude like
where did he go like you know he's
probably dead right or he got turned
into a vampire but they didn't they
showed him later like Simon the brother
who was even who was kind of boring
honestly he was kind of a little bit of
a boring character like the man horror
was a lot more interesting I thought but
um but yeah so Simon ends up in that in
that room that you can't get to like
unless you can walk down walls like
Dracula can he ends up in there and then
he finds his brother like essentially
like staked to the wall like he's dead
obviously yeah he was inside that uh I
was like wow that's some Texas Chainsaw
Massacre [__] right there he's inside
that secret chamber yeah sticking on a
spike yeah dra didn't even throw his ass
out he could have just throwing him out
the going to leave him in here as a
decoration leave in here to rock yeah
which okay Dracula has some weird like
Decora aesthetic I guess like I said
it's like some Leatherface [__] you're
just going to like hang dead bodies up
on the wall yeah it's like I like it
it's just kind of like [__] that's
that's my whole well it looked good on
it looked good on camera yeah yeah just
like I said it's what he probably
doesn't mind I he probably doesn't mind
like the smell or anything like that
Danny rling said did Tom and Jenny ever
see that Nicholas Cage Dracula film
Renfield yet and if so was it good yeah
I just watched it the other day um Tom
was not home I think you saw like a
little bits and pieces of it like CU
yeah he was out at bike night and I was
watching it um I really liked it it's
yeah it's it's very overtly a comedy so
go into it and it kind of had it went in
directions I didn't expect a little bit
because it's almost kind of like a crime
film yeah but with Dracula and Renfield
in it and it is very overtly funny but
like most of the funniest [__] was like
the Gory [__] and the fight scenes I
mean the [__] there was some [__] in
here where people were just like
exploding and they were just like
breaking people like pulling people's
arms off and beating people with the arm
kind like Ash and evil death yeah it was
kind of like that like not quite as
funny as that but it was just kind of
along those lines so if you go into it
um knowing that it's very overtly a
comedy but it's like pretty gory too
then it'll be good and like Nicholas
Cage is always entertaining to watch
because he just
always um does the most bizarre [__]
possible and he's like it's pretty
bizarre in this one but I was kind of
into it I liked it but yeah so now okay
now Tom had a problem a little bit with
the ending of this what happens at the
end of this movie like obviously they
have this whole you know after they find
the brother dead and everything so they
um they kind of think that clove is
going to help them out but then he kind
of [__] them over and it's just this
whole thing and then Sarah is going to
be the new bride so obviously they can't
let that happen so they get up on the
roof Sarah's up there now she has a
crucifix on so he hasn't be able to bite
her because of course he's just kind of
like oh my God but he gets his little
bat familiar who we never find out I
guess it's a familiar yeah I suppose
that's what we decided yeah cuz I was
just like well I thought it was going to
be a person but it's clearly not a
person like or another vampire that was
likeing him out yeah it's his trained
bat so which you know handy so he gets
the bat to pull the crucifix off her and
you get a really nice shot of her tit
with blood all over scratched which
again I was just kind of like oh all
right yeah we like that well like I said
that was pretty out there even for
Hammer like showing like super bloody
tits like that like all scratched up
bloody tits and I was just kind of like
okay so we're going to another level
here I see what you're doing so he gets
her to so he gets the bad to pull that
off so he can like attack her but then
um so clove comes and he kind of get he
starts stabbing at Dracula because I
guess he's decided no I'm going to save
the woman I love from her picture even
though I don't know her and then he gets
[__] again like [__] chucked off
the cat he's like bye all right so he
just throws him off and then um like so
what happens is that Simon I think then
like the brother yeah he pulls off the
spike and he throws it like he's [__]
at the Olympics you know what I mean he
throws it throws it like a jabin he
throws like a javelin and then he kind
of Misses though because he kind of gets
him in the stomach and Dracula's like
what the
that's like not even my heart or
whatever and so then he lifts up the
thing and he's I'm going to stab Simon
and time it's like oh [__] this is like
going throw this he's going to throw it
back he's going to yeah he's going to
throw it in he's just standing there
waiting for the thing to get throw it
[__] that kills me like in old horror
movies everyone just kind of stands
there and like allows people to kill
them he's like don't throw it he's not
even I'm like just can you run or he's
not even Tak action and the and the
girl's just sitting there going ah she's
not running either I not yeah like I
said up until probably the early 1970s I
feel like because you see this a lot in
Gala movies too like some like Intruder
like breaks in someone's house and like
the woman will literally just like be
there backed against the wall screaming
while the dude comes out I'm like can
you run or go get a weapon or something
please be proactive like go hide at
least like try to jump out the window
something but yeah nobody ever does
everybody just yes okay I guess this is
my now don't kill me oh okay I won't bye
yeah so there's that kind of thing see
he [__] back the Dracula [__] back
that [__] metal rod right it's it's a
metal spear to throw it through the dude
and he gets struck by lightning and he
catches on fire that kills him and I was
like I'm not sure yeah I kind of like it
but Tom was like yeah but that kind of
negates the whole yeah thing of the hero
like he he would have died if nature
hadn't intervened maybe they were maybe
the movie May yeah yeah maybe the movie
was trying to say well
God struck him down I don't think so I
think it was pure luck yeah he was just
like oh I'm holding up this thing which
is kind of like a lightning rod like a
[__] for a hero you know if they want he
didn't really do anything if they wanted
to kill him that way he should have done
something to make to to cause that to
happen right you know what I mean yeah I
get what you're saying like he's cocking
cocking back like that you know and he
goes oh yeah yeah I got my [__] kite
and he puts his kite on it and light
heit hits the kite like like some Ben
Franklin Ben Frank
or they should have had something to
where cuz that really did seem like well
what if lightning hadn't struck you'd be
in [__] trouble wouldn't you like
you'd be dead and your girlfriend would
be a vampire bride so although she
seemed okay and there wasn't much
lightning going on it was just Lightning
Out of Nowhere boom right I think it was
I think in the background they were
trying to make it look like there was
some lightning but no if had it been a
real intense electrical stor maybe you'd
be able to buy it a little bit more like
had lightning struck in a couple of the
locations and then he's trying to
maneuver Dracula into a place where the
lightning would hit him something like
that right you know that yeah as it was
it really did seem like it relied on
which like I said you can't yeah that
happens in real life all the time but
well not that you kill a vampire by
being struck by lightning that doesn't
happen ever but I'm just saying that you
know lucky [__] happens all the time or
unlucky [__] but in a movie you can't
really I mean there has to be like some
kind of the main character has to be
kind of
proactive in the plot and the fact that
that Simon had spent all this time
looking for his brother and he did all
this investigation and everything and
then he gets up there with the final
confrontation and it ends up that pure
luck yeah that that's what ended up
killing the vampire yeah I didn't love
it I didn't love it so you know that he
it looked good like it looked dramatic
cuz it's like oh [__] like a lightning
rod and then he catches on fire and
falls off the side of the cast there was
no no need for him there was no need he
could have been killed before yeah he
didn't even need to be there he need to
be there he could have been killed
before I mean the only thing he did was
throw that Spear and it h so the spear
happened to be in Dracula's hand like
like a lightning rod when the lightning
struck so okay but other than that like
he didn't really even need to be there
the girl could have thrown the spear
right that's what I mean like you didn't
you didn't even need that character in
fact that would have been really cool if
she like done it she'd have been like
yeah [__] you [__] he's standing
on top of the [__] Tip Top of the
castle gloating waving that spear around
in the middle of an electrical storm
that would be a little more believable
yeah actually I kind of like that but
they never made the they the hammer
movies I guess cuz they were going back
to like the older Gothic tradition so
like the women in them were usually like
damsels in distress they didn't
usually do much of anything yeah they
just kind of like stood there they were
too Victorian to do anything right
that's what I'm saying they just kind of
like stood there and being like well I
guess we're all going to get killed yeah
you know of course it's too tight yeah
well I get that they were running around
they were running around and heel I
can't run too fast my little
heels yeah and like I said I get I get
that like cuz course it's do restrict
your movement to to a great degree
because it's coming from someone that
wears them all the time yeah so I get it
I'm just kind of like man I can't
[__] move right now I'm not even
going to try and kill this vampire right
now this is like too much for me but
yeah I they didn't really do that a lot
in those movies and I get it that wasn't
that's not like of the genre I guess but
yeah it probably would have been better
if she yeah we didn't even need that
character no honestly she just could
have been like why didn't they make
[__] Paul her boyfriend right and that
kind of would have added some like extra
the cast P to it because it's like kind
of like well he was like [__] around
on her but she's like I still love him
and I'm going to save him and it's like
so she could have saved him cuz that
Simon dude didn't need to be there he
didn't have to be there but they just
you know they needed a hot chick and
they needed like they always have to
have this love interesting and like I
said they kind of it hinted at the
beginning of the movie that like they
were going to set it up like these two
brothers Paul and Simon were both
gunning for the same woman and she
couldn't decide cuz there was a whole
thing at the beginning there's like a
party like it was her birthday party
right and there was a whole thing where
Simon gave her a present and it was a
ring which was clearly like it didn't
look like an engagement ring but it
still could have been and so he and he
kind of and she put it on and she's like
oh it's beautiful and he's like oh I was
hoping you'd put it on your other hand
like so he was implying that he was
trying to ask her to marry him and she
was just kind of like yeah I can't do
this right now and then they were kind
of talking about Paul and you kind of
thought that maybe she was more into
Paul than him but then they didn't
really kind of follow up on that cuz I
thought it was going to be this whole
like love triangle thing and I think it
was supposed to be originally but I
think they just kind of like abandoned
it halfway through too much trouble yeah
because as it went on it became clear
that you know Simon and Sarah were a
thing and then it was just kind of like
and she's just like oh he's your brother
and and I'm worried about him like they
just kind of did that still out of the
two movies I liked this one better I did
too I did too like it because it was
just more lurid it was just more
Christopher Lee was in it a lot more he
did really [__] up [__] in it which I
thought was kind of cool because you
didn't really see him doing all of that
you like I said a lot of the sequels he
wasn't in it that much they focus too
much on the boring characters yeah
exactly in this one you get to see
[__] Dracula behind the scenes
unedited uncensored what ises that
[__] doing being cruel being
being stabbing [__] saying hey
cut that [__] up and throw her in acid
get controlling with women stabing his
girlfriends did he just he was bad
getting all the bats to kill all the
women in the village all the women in
the church they left all the women in
there and they were all [__] up and
they were all and I was just like damn
that is picking up [__] par maids and
enjoying them and then getting sick of
them something we allire sick of and
then kill her too don't you cuz she goes
I love you how dare you what you know
you don't need her you got me and he's
like [__] you [__] bam it kills
her yeah he's not Dracula's not woman
Dracula's not not I don't need no
woman I mean I guess he doesn't I mean I
guess it would be lonely after a while
being a vampire and whatnot but the kind
of dude that they're that they're
showing it he doesn't give a [__] he's
evil you he he doesn't care yeah well
and we've said this I think he's around
just to just to make them
miserable and make them miserable and
make them obedient yeah that's he's he's
one of those yeah that's the thing about
Christopher Lee's Dracula which in a way
is is one of his strengths I think is
that he never comes across like oh man
I'm so bummed that I'm a vampire um he's
just kind of like a just a powerful
cruel yeah it's real cruel yeah yeah um
dude and he just doesn't seem like to
have existential crises about it or
anything like that no he's just kind of
like Yeah I'm going to eat all you
[__] I don't even care about it
he's he's cool about it he like oh yeah
yeah this this is what I do and like I
said there's I like a lot of different
actors interpretations of it and there's
a lot to be said for giving him some
like gravitas and giving him some you
know like he has some Melancholy to him
because it's like yeah it would be a
bummer like living that long but I do
kind of like Christopher Lee's take on
it where he's just like this ruthless
yeah big [__] like he doesn't like he
seems to enjoy being a vamp he doesn't
even seem to enjoy it he just seems like
to embody it you know yeah well when
you're meeting him he'll give you
something to drink and he'll be all
polite and you know civilized but that's
not who he is right that's yeah he's
just like a that's just a veneer yeah
he's just like this cruel like warlord
type charact and I think that's good
that's maybe like closer to the they
talking about yeah Joseph Green says
worst Christopher Lee movie howling too
your sister's a werewolf okay I don't
think I can argue too much with that
howling too howling too your sister's a
werewolf that's what that's called yeah
I didn't know there was a howling too we
started watching it the other day I saw
it okay I saw it a couple of times on
cable back in the 80s yeah yeah I was
thinking wolfin no no no wolin's good
and actually we should review wolfin at
some point cuz I cuz I want to rewatch
it the howling and then the first
howling is fantastic and the howling too
I remember was just it's unwatchable
yeah so that's the thing like we like I
saw it a bunch of times on cable back in
the day and I'm just kind of like oh
okay you know it was the 80s our
standards were lower so so we started
watching it it was probably like 3 years
ago cuz we were still at the old house
and we started watching it and you were
just kind of like this is like un
[__] watchable and I'm like yeah I
agree yeah that was just like scanners
was great and I remembered liking
scanners too put scanners 2 on it's
unfuck watch couldn't get through that
[__] like not even 20 minutes so people
talk about movies being shitty nowadays
like they were shitty back then too it's
just like back then like I said your
standards were lower I remember watching
the entirety of howling to your sister's
a werewolf a couple of times like when
it was on cable and being like yeah that
was all right but like watching it now
I'm like how the what the [__] was I on
like why did I sit there that's the way
it was when I was uh transcfers I
thought first transc he kept telling me
about it I remembered it being a [__]
cool movie oh it's so awesome man that
movie [__] sucks sucks and then we
watched it not too long ago what the I
on Blu-ray I kept he bought it what the
[__] and I kept looking at him going
like is this the movie you were talking
about this is terrible yeah terrible
Terri
only the opening scene is okay the
opening scene is good I will give it
that but after that I'm just like what
the [__] is happening right now we were
teenagers when we saw it maybe the
opening scene just puts you in the mood
for a good movie and when you're [__]
teenager you don't realize that the
movie sucks were you perhaps high and
were getting a [__] at the same time
not going blow job no or something no no
that was Texas Chainsaw M yeah Texas
Chainsaw M see I know everything I got
blown I know everything about I got BL
all way through that thing yeah Cheryl
he even remembers her name yeah back in
high the girl that blew me in high
school while I was watching Texas
Chainsaw Massac yeah but yeah so that's
why more than once while we watching I
[__] took a rest and then she went
back to we making out stuff Dr Texas CH
about the whole movie and didn't
remember I didn't remember was it during
the end part which which is just like
you know an hour of screaming here's the
funny here's the funny thing I think I
only saw like the first five minutes of
the movie then I was already you check
yeah I was checking out I was doing
other [__] that's a shame cuz Texas
chainsa massacre is a great [__]
movie no man we in her in her [__]
basement rec wck
room parents upstairs too oh my God yeah
and they were just kind of like oh
they're probably just studying oh yeah
they're okay they knew what was going on
probably did we were quiet they knew
what was going quiet well yeah we could
hear them coming down you you could hear
them walking across the ceiling well
[__] man if I had that if I had a
basement recck room and stuff I'd have
put like bells and [__] across the
[__] no they couldn't sneak up on you
yeah that's what I'm saying um somebody
said where was it somebody said earlier
Bill 33 says happy Halloween to my
favorite movie critics thanks a thank
you very much um Karen Lee said I liked
Franken hooker yeah it a good movie but
could not yeah okay I mean yeah we
reviewed Franken hooker I love Franken
hooker it's good it's actually pretty
well made it is and well I kind of like
it's coherent it's a coherent movie yeah
you wouldn't think that from the name
yeah but had some good ideas honestly I
saw it back in the old days like when it
came back in the 80s
but we watched it again recently a year
or two ago like whenever we did the
years ago and um and it was much better
than I remembered that doesn't always
happen but it happens more often than
not I feel like when I watch movies that
I liked from back then about 85% of the
time I'm like wow that's actually much
better than I remembered yeah Basket
Case was better than I remember yeah
like the other 15% of the time I'm like
oh that is substantially worse than I
remembered but usually it's usually it's
positive usually I'm like oh my God this
is way better than I well and it helps
too that a lot of those movies have been
re um you know
remastered and they look a lot better
than when because I just saw them like
on some shitty small like you know TV or
something like that or on VHS so they
didn't look as good so when you see them
now and they've been like restored and
everything like they were supposed to
look like in the theater I'm like wow
this is actually like really competently
shot and like the cinematography is nice
and stuff like that which like back in
the day I was like wow this movie looked
like it cost a buck 98 yeah but nowadays
you see it's like oh it looks like an
actual movie what is you guys what is
your guilty pleasure horror movie ooh
guilty pleasure I don't have a
sensations of guilt yeah I'm not really
guilty about anything but guilty
pleasure uh I'm trying to think of like
like a movie that a lot of people don't
like that I really like the only thing I
don't know why this came into my mind
and I haven't seen it in a while so
please take this with a grain of salt a
lot of people hated the BL Blair
Witch uh sequel Blair Witch 2 book of
shadows and I saw it and I was like that
was pretty [__] good I haven't seen
it in a long time though so it might
suck I'm not really sure but I remember
seeing it like when it came out and
really liking it people don't like Alien
versus Predator 2 but I like that movie
yeah I like I like I thought it was cool
I'm pretty like look I love horror yeah
and I'm pretty open to whatever so it's
like I'm pretty forgiving to too because
I've seen like I said I'm a big MST 3K
fan so I have seen the worst of the
worst like just terrible terrible movies
that were made on like a nothing but
like for like a dollar and even the kind
of worst like people that talk about oh
it's the worst movie ever in blahy blah
not even close not even close yeah not
they'll say uh Halloween 3 was bad I
loved Halloween 3 and I feel like that's
a movie that thankfully has gotten a
reassessment cuz when that came out
people were really mad where's Michael
Myers and why is this I didn't I never
saw one or two I just saw three but it's
like nowadays it's just kind of like
nowadays like everybody is just kind of
like what that's a [__] good movie
like yeah didn't have M that's okay
didn't need to have Michael Myers in we
got enough movies of Michael Myers in
yeah it's just in the universe but it's
not about that yeah well and I like that
Exorcist 3 also got a reassessment cuz
that is an awesome [__] movie yeah
Exorcist 3 is an awesome movie Exorcist
2 on the other hand is kind of shitty
there's something kind of good about thr
a weird it has its moments it has its
moments [__] what's his we did review
that his name [__] uh Richard
Burton yeah Richard Burton's [__]
drunk ass carrying the movie [__]
Richard Burton was a trip man he was you
could tell he was drinking on set yeah
that was his style you he just looked
loaded well he was probably at some
point they were just kind of like if he
showed up sober they were just like
what's the matter with you yeah they
weren't used we hired you because you
look like a drunk man come on and he was
a really good doctor he was he really
good yeah you can tell he [__] drunk
man three sheets to the [__]
[Laughter]
wi Camp guy says Evil Dead one and two
my wife and I won't even watch this
anymore we getting too old a that's a
shame no they're good I love Evil Dead
one and two honestly I probably like
Evil Dead 2 better than well I don't
know it's hard it's I like them both the
same they're they're essentially the
same movie but one is like a higher
budget see the Japanese version what was
it muscle muscle man no body bodybuilder
muscle what the [__] is the name of that
body builder muscle muscle bodybuilder
in Hell something like that it's it's
it's the Japanese evil and it's from the
90s right like or early 90s and it was
made for like a nothing budget yeah like
it homages uh Evil Dead one a lot it's
like the Japanese well I think the
alternate title is the Japanese Evil
Dead But like I said it was made a long
time ago yeah and and it's super fun
like we just it's on shudder I think
it's a trip and it might be on tub as
well but yeah that was super fun so um
Danny Rowling said Blair Witch 2 is the
best one yeah I liked that it went like
meta fiction I you know I kind of liked
that idea uh talking about pumpkin head
is good yeah I love pumpkin head pumpkin
head pumpkin head to sucked though yeah
that one wasn't great but the first one
was really good I really liked the the
whole idea of the like the Revenge demon
you could like go to the Village witch
and be like hey this person [__] me
over like bring up pumpkin head and like
have go [__] him up that's like a cool
idea fun what was funny though is that
like this weird premise
where in the in the mountains of
California you you're going back into
time you end up in [__] yeah it's
like when did I suddenly end up in like
graes of Wrath you're now in
1920 when you when you go up to the
mountains of California yeah all these
poor people wearing coveralls and Shacks
like the O like the like the [__]
with old old 1920s cars yeah none of
that [__] [__] like that hadn't existed
in a long long time at that time but
they were just trying to make it feel
like you were going back in time deal
with those people but it was funny they
were still in
California well well the thing about it
is that well we have to shoot it in
California because of the budget it's
like I'm sure they probably wanted to
shoot it like I said in the middle of
the [__] yeah you know Ozarks or
something but it's like they couldn't
afford to so like just going to pretend
that this is like some super Backwoods
right kind of [__] but like in the
middle of California right the only
places that would be like that is where
the damn inbred family is up there in
the [__] was that in the
uh [__] in like the Appalachian in the
Appalachian yeah in the Appalachian
Mountains that's the only place where
where it's where you'd ever have a
chance to see anything that's kind of
what I where I pretend pumpkin and and
they don't look like that anymore they
big old jeno [__] Rave jeans and blue
hair and meth that's what they look like
well no that's Lake County Lake County
that's that's where that's where we live
yeah but they look like that there too I
know yeah yeah yeah rednecks here a lot
a lot of them don't look like you know
I'm not I'm not using that as an ethnic
slur you know we're we're of redneck
blood but [__] I grew up in a trailer
park in Daytona Beach for Christ's sake
you can't get much more redneck than
that right it's
uh they're they're not all these country
people you know where they look like
listening to country western music and I
mean some of them are to be fair but a
lot of them are just look like they came
from a rave in
1998 yeah there's out of date 1998
clothes [__] green hair bad piercings
and just and their their hair hasn't
been dyed in weeks well I kind of feel
like the 9s is like has made it come
back made to come back here I don't
think it ever left they just stayed like
that which is unfortunate yeah cuz I
[__] hated the '90s yeah well I hated
a lot of aspects yeah I hat a lot of
aspects of the90s like I said I hated
that whole like [__] the whole the 9s
decade to me seemed like the the decade
of the edge Lord and I was just kind of
like I hated that [__] [__] look how
[__] crazy we are we're so crazy
funny what's
funny it's so try hard yeah we'll go to
the mall and we'll see them like that in
those 90s clothes but they're just new
reversions of the '90s clo but then
they're updated like some of them are
gender non-binary yeah they're like 16
they 16-year-old gender non-binary
lesbian couple in 1990s Rave clothes
[__] badir in Lake County in Lake
County in the midd in Central Florida
like in the middle of like it's it's a
rural rural as [__] it's like farms and
[__] super funny yeah it's super weird I
mean it's kind of cool but it's also
kind of weird cuz it's like it's not
just a weird mixture of [__] [__] it
is a real weird and and it's funny too
because you know CU we go to cuz we're
kind of like old but also um we like a
lot of protein and we like a good
bargain yeah um we also go to the buffet
a lot like on the weekends Chinese
buffet the Chinese buffet yeah get
shrimp [__] it's funny when you go in
there because it's like probably 90% of
the people in there are exactly what you
would expect like just these dumpy yeah
kind of Backwoods not Backwoods but
they're like you know what I mean like
kind of just dumpy white well a lot of
them a lot of them [__] out of those
dumpy retirees a lot of them from are
from up North very up overweight
Northerners and stuff because I'll hear
Yankee accents and stuff because uh this
retirement villages around
here yeah and not too far from where the
buffet is there's like a whole bunch of
big like mobile home parks yeah CU but
then there's like really nice
neighborhoods too like really nice like
gated communities but then there's like
all these mobile home mixure you'll have
[__] real well to do and poor right
next to each other yeah and they're all
going and getting some [__] all you
can eat Chinese I was sit there getting
some ice cream [__] at the at the
Chinese buffet and they had a dude he's
probably about 60 mid 60s late late 60s
and he was just just straight up New
Yorker little New York guy Just Fish Out
of Water he's like what you know just
you could tell he was just very out of
place very out of
place but you they you know big just the
mannerisms and the the accent and the
clothing I don't maybe he hadn't been
here long yeah probably not because a
lot of them become kind of they just
move here and just he's like whoa whoa
where am I you know cuz I mean a lot of
the people in there like I said are just
these kind of like people that kind of
like people that I grew up with in
Daytona these just kind of like big
dumpy white people that were just kind
of like hey let's go to Cracker Barrel
you it's that kind of [__] yeah you
drive around you see a lot of old IR
rocks and Trans Ams yeah and
[__] yeah irck and Trans Ams irck Z
[__] it's what yeah it's a little bit
they have a [__] Trans Am and that
[__] will be brought back to almost
like Factory new yeah yeah um Danny
Rowling says the 1987 Canon film Hansel
and gredle starring David Warner and
chloris leechman is on the same level as
The Witches 1990 pretty dark for a Kids
film um I don't think I've ever seen
that and honestly I'm going to have to
see that now because that sounds I've
heard of it but I've never seen it that
sounds like pretty [__] amazing John
Robertson said if I could could I would
bring back Christopher Lee Peter Cushing
and Vincent Price and have them play
vampires in a modern vampire movie with
special effects and Gothic Ambiance I
would love that I mean Sebastian's
asking for [__] um count yoro countor
yeah I been want to do like we should do
because I think there was two count
yorga movies right we should probably do
both of them yeah I remember seeing it's
been a long time since I've seen that
one that was an American movie wasn't it
Gail yorga now I can't remember okay
maybe that'll be the next next one that
we do cuz I think it's available
somewhere I think I just saw it on tub
or some place like cuz I was thinking
about doing it I think I put it in the
poll a couple times but it never won Dan
ring said 90s people are more tolerable
than modern hipsters in my opinion I
guess it depends I guess it depends but
you know some of that shit's pretty
dated man it is but you know whatever
they yeah if that's what they want to
look like then I'm just not going to
you're like jenos went out man a long
time I'm not going to get concerned
about it I remember when were new yeah I
do too and uh yeah man The South was
filled with I was living in Mississippi
at the
time South was fil filled with cute
Southern Rave looking girls with belly
rings and tongue rings and [__] oh that
was very big yeah and they were they
were hot [__] too it was just a good
thing about
them that was another time though he
loves the [__] oh yeah
yeah and it was but it was new that
wasn't an old look yeah you know what I
mean it's kind of like the mullet yeah
that haircut it's not a redneck haircut
start out like that redne got a hold of
that they saw that [__] in New Way
ruined then they stayed with it forever
they saw that if they saw that in
[__] new wave videos man probably
like kachugo or something yeah video
they man that's a stylish haircut or
even some members of Durant Durant had
had M back in the day John Taylor
probably more than the other although
you no I think Andy Taylor had had the
most egregious mullet and it wasn't
called a mullet back then it was just
hair yeah it was just hair and honestly
like a lot like what you would consider
a mullet nowadays like back in the early
80s that was like a very new wave it a
new wave yeah yeah like a lot of new
wave bands out that hair and like
nowadays you look at it and go like holy
[__] that's a mullet Yeah it's red neck
as [__] yeah I don't think they call
that a mullet until like way later yeah
much later like
after after like I said like all the all
the kind of rednecks had adopted that
hair for whatever reason get a hold of
something they'll keep it for decades
man yeah they're like why change it yeah
that's a good one man we're gonna keep
that it looks good like that yeah
yeah Danny rling said a lot of Latins
rock molets yeah yeah I mean John gor
said what's the one with Caroline Monroe
about the Vampire Hunter oh I know what
one you're talking about oh [__] yeah
Tom loves Carolina yeah she's a warrior
of love she is yes yes yeah um man in
the Sinbad movies when I was a kid man
[__] my babysitter Kimmy took me see
that [__] man [__] I was just
surrounded by these beautiful women and
[__] beautiful teenage girls and
[__] car all just blending in
together man oh my God Tom could take it
it was overwhelming I was about seven
yeah yeah these beautiful older women 12
you know they're like 12 and I'm just
Captain Kronos that's what it was Kronos
Captain Kronos vampire yeah that's
another one we need to do that's another
way we need to do but uh yeah [__]
mullets man you have a mullet wig do you
not yeah somewhere I haven't I haven't
rocked the wigs in a while yeah you
haven't play wi wig games well we're
doing reviews so it's not time maybe on
sidetracks we can do it yeah all right
so I guess we're gonna wrap it up we've
been on for hour and 40 minutes oh yeah
it's a long one and I think well well I
I was having fun like talking about
these but you know I love Christopher
Leah and I love the hammer movies so we
were just talking about these it's not a
clock though okay all right
so uh thank every thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super Chats on
the Wednesday show we're going to be
doing uh we're going to be talking about
Michael Jackson yeah it's going to be
good show yeah it should be entertaining
like about we're not going to talk
mysteries of Michael yeah like not his
whole life or anything like that we're
going to be talking about like the
controversies like about you know the
abuse he doing it yeah and and but maybe
a little bit about like the controversy
surrounding his death and stuff but I
will say that we watched um the HBO
documentary what's it called leaving
Neverland yeah it's about 4 hours we
watched that last night and I don't know
man like I was kind of like on the fence
prior to this but then I I started
reading stuff and then like we watched
that documentary last night and I'm like
o I don't know I don't know how much on
the fence I am anymore yeah um I made my
mind up we'll see that that [__] made
too much sense I was like oh yeah yeah
and I was just kind yeah and I was just
kind of like typical male Behavior yeah
it well yeah you should just just just
the target of his desire was different
yeah but no I mean yeah and and the
thing about it Camp guy said I love
Michael Jackson like off-the-wall one of
the best albums in history yeah and the
thing about it is that I don't like when
I look into because look like a lot of
musicians or writers or stuff like that
that I really like were horrible
people and that doesn't diminish the um
you know the the influence of their work
or you know how much I enjoy their work
or something like that like it maybe
taints it a little bit cuz I do kind of
think about it but I don't know I in a
lot of lot of ways I think you have to
separate the person from the artist
because like somebody that is a
brilliant writer or a brilliant musician
or a brilliant artist or something like
that can still be like a [__] human
being yeah although I don't think
Michael Jackson was a bad person or a
[__] human being I think he had serious
problems yeah and yeah and we'll kind of
get into that'll get into it because
it's just kind of like yeah I don't
think he didn't see himself as a bad
person like I well yeah well a lot of
bad people don't like yeah so we might
talk about that too cuz that's like a
fascinating I'm like fascinated that
kind of [__] so we might get into that
but yeah so so now they're all doing
[__] what is that Danny rolling is
doing the he yeah like grabbing yeah
yeah yeah grabing he was a trip man [__]
we grew up watching that dude I was I
kind of put him I consider him to be I I
kind of put him in a way like on par
with Elvis kind of where Elvis was kind
of a shitty person too like a little bit
well that's not what I meant what I
meant was is that I wasn't a big fan of
their music right
but they're very interesting yeah guys
you know they're kind of like huge stars
and they're interesting in how that
affects the
mind and what strange lives that they
lived when you're that famous you're
basically a prisoner you can't really go
anywhere that's I mean you can't really
have a normal life which really can't
that can't be like mentally healthy and
I kind of feel like that manifests in a
lot of really fascinating ways yeah
which is always which is not always fun
for like the people around them
obviously but Jackson had some [__]
secrets man and and uh but no listening
to listening to the testimony and
testimony is not evidence in a court of
law but it's testimony it can persuade
you I was persuaded no when I heard when
I
heard when I heard the stories and there
are stories that took place over decades
and yeah okay it makes it makes a lot
more sense sound pretty plausible yeah
it makes a lot more
sense when you hear the stories of
people that were up and close and
personal with him you know of what he
was like and uh so my curiosity was
satisfied I made it my mind yeah we'll
talk about it on the show like I said I
don't really know if I have because I
wasn't there but I'm just saying that
99% yeah I kind of got like a little
pushed off the fence it makes a lot more
sense their story makes a lot more sense
than the story you're seeing when you're
looking at Michael Jackson at Neverland
and where the [__] his girlfriend He's
33 years old man that place should be
dripping with [__] single women and
porn stars and actresses and [__] that's
what say see if was that rich and famous
oh compound like that yeah he would have
the whole place there would be naked
women on every available serent yeah
yeah it would it would look it would it
would look it would be like it would
look like a palace first of all they' be
they' be partying all the time I'm not
going to have a [__] train and a
ferris wheel and [__] out the front
yard what about I hang out with kids for
talking about man yeah kids are kind of
lame get them the [__] out of here man
I'd have a [__] they can't drink or
anything I'd have helicopter landing
pads and [__] Jets and [__] and
[__] you know try to buy a flying
saucer you know that do anything but I
wouldn't have I you try an amusement
park I might have an amusement park but
not for kids I'd have an adult amusement
park yeah it would have it would have a
real AMC Theater that could like fit
yeah I would do that 100 people i' I'd
have a McDonald's and a Pizza Hut I
don't want a Pizza Hut I'd no I would
just have some yeah I would have Pizza
Hut [__] it or Papa John's I'd have a
Papa John's and he wouldn't be staffed
all the time it's just that you know
what I mean
I think I'd rather wanted to go get some
pizza get a call you get give me a pizza
ready now i' go down to [__] Papa
John's I had my own parking lot out
there you don't even like in town but
it's my personal town you know yeah yeah
Tom going have a whole town well you
could have your friends over and they
would be like you were hanging out in
town yeah well that's kind of what this
place was like it had like kind of hotel
rooms and [__] like that too but like
where people could stay could stay yeah
but I get it but like for kids it was
awesome but I'm not averse to am I love
amusement parks I'm just saying that I
would make it more like an adult
amusement park I would have like a huge
big bar and like all like nightclubs and
then like also also like roll I'd have
roller coasters and [__] I'm not saying
that it look like Miami i' have all
these pools multi-layered pools [__]
fountains and [__] and awesome yeah they
[__] hire
[__] erotic entertainers to come over
and [__] have them hang out parties
and [__] strippers up on the stripper
that's what lesbo a and [__] on
spotlights on him so that's why Tom has
always been a little suspicious of
Michael Jackson because he didn't have
any of that he didn't have any of that
and a 30-year old man of that much
wealth and fame would definitely have
that I mean yeah because they do yeah
that's what I mean if you had all that
money and no one to tell you not to do
that right then you would do that
because he wasn't married it have been a
bachelor pad yeah but you know all right
we'll get into that on say we don't want
to waste it all um but yeah uh so thanks
for dropping by listen to us talk about
Hammer movies hopefully you can come by
on Wednesday listen to us talk about
Michael
Jackson and so we will see you guys then
have a good day tomorrow good
night